I've hit a stalemate I know a lot of
people hit stalemates but YouTube shorts
I know you've been talking about that
lately is that the future like where the
people have moved to it's not that they
moved there okay but to your point
people hit stalemates and there's only
two ways you could fix that go to new
places to distribute your content or
push yourself creatively to make
different kinds of content that's a big
push that my team's doing right now
right Dustin like this morning I posted
I said hey I want to do more handwritten
notes with video overlay and sure enough
it's crushing right now because it's a
little different creatively everyone
makes the same content you get into ruts
you got to mix it up are you gonna do a
little green screen right are you going
to do a duet are you going to draw are
you going to be in front of the camera
behind the camera interview people
people aren't mixing it enough which is
why people are hitting ruts they're
hitting ruts not because they're getting
Shadow banned or their algorithms
hurting them they're hitting ruts
because they're creatively in a rut